we are continuing with our series the roots of
truth and our subject for today is cain and abel
and as always because someone may just view one of
the six entries in this series it is important for
me to explain why we chose the theme the roots of
truth and the simple reason is the major doctrines
of the bible as they have to do with salvation
are all rooted and they originate in the first
three chapters of the book of genesis i'm
referring to righteousness sin probation the law
the second coming forgiveness all of
these things have the origin within the
first three chapters of genesis
and sometimes within the first
11 and hence the title the roots of truth
and our subject for today is cain and abel
but before getting into that subject again we want
to remind you that jesus used this method of study
by going to the beginning when he answered the
pharisees in matthew 19 verse 3 when they said
is it lawful for a man to put away his wife for
every cause and jesus said have ye not read that
he which made them at the beginning and so we have
the example of jesus christ going back to a time
before sin to answer a question that emerged
from the sinful dispensation and this is the
technique he used in luke 24 27 where the bible
says and beginning at moses and all the prophets
he expounded into them in all the scriptures the
things concerning himself so christ would explain
scripture by beginning as early as he could to
make clear whatever particular subject he was
discussing so the roots of truth and the subject
is cain and abel i've always said that if
all bibles were banned by law the one book
i would like to have is steps to christ
but if the government were to say
you can have a part of the bible
and that part can only be composed of three
chapters my three chapters would be genesis 1 2
and 3. now some of you may choose revelation 12 13
14 or daniel 7 8 and 9 which is all fine my three
would be genesis 1 2 and 3 which tells the story
of how things began how things went wrong and the
solution to what went wrong which is really the
essence of human history so we'll be looking again
at the early chapters of the bible genesis 1 2
and 3 as we discussed the subject cain and abel
now let me explain why i chose that title cain
and abel i am dealing with righteousness and sin
which again each one can take up weeks of
presentations but we haven't got that so
i'm trying to condense a lot of material into
one presentation go to first john well let's go
to hebrews 11 and we'll read verse 4. hebrews 11
verse 4 our subject is cain and abel hebrews 11
reading verse 4 and i hope we've all turned
off our cell phones and there is no disturbance
during this worship experience hebrews chapter
11 verse 4 the bible says by faith abel offered
unto god a more excellent sacrifice than cain by
which he obtained witness that he was righteous
god testifying of his gifts and by it he being
dead yet speaketh the verse tells us that abel
received testimony that he was righteous and that
testimony came from god himself and so we want to
take a look at this thing called righteousness now
in first john chapter 3 we shall read verse 11 and
12 verses 11 and 12 of first john chapter 3 our
subject is cain and abel or sin and righteousness
first john 3 verse 11 for this is the message that
we heard from the beginning that we shall love one
another not as cain who was of that wicked one
and slew his brother and wherefore slew he him
because his own works were evil and his
brothers righteous in that verse 12 of
1st john 3 we have two opposites and one way to
define what something is is to say what it is not
and so by reading first john 3 12 we can get some
reliable information as to what righteousness
is and what sin is hebrews 11 says abel offered
unto god a more excellent sacrifice than cain
by which he obtained witness he was righteous we
may safely conclude if abel was declared righteous
cain clearly was declared to be unrighteous why
what abel did was right what ken did was wrong
let us take a look at what genesis has to say
let's go to genesis chapter four and we shall
read from verse one genesis chapter four
reading from verse one our subject is cain
and abel we're looking at these two massive themes
sin and righteousness and adam knew his wife
and she conceived and bear cain and said i have
gotten a man from the lord and she again bear his
brother abel and abel was a keeper of sheep but
cain was the tiller of the ground and in process
of time it came to pass that cain brought of the
fruit of the ground an offering unto the lord
an able he also brought of the firstlings of
his flock and of the fat thereof and the lord
had respect unto abel and to his offering but
unto cain and to his offering he had not respect
and cain was very wroth and his countenance
fell now look at verse four and verse five
and the lord had respect and to
able and to his offering but to cain
and to his offering he had not respect now we
have god demonstrating two opposite responses
the one he demonstrated to cain was
precisely opposite to his attitude
towards abel and we have to understand why cain
became very angry his countenance fell for six
and the lord said unto cain why are thou wrath now
remember god is a god who loves to reason with us
so he invites us to reason isaiah 1
180 and come now let us reason together
and if we will reason as we study the word of
god light would flash into our minds of course
you combine reasoning with an honest heart and a
willingness to obey what you learn why are thou
wroth says god and why is that countenance fallen
if thou doest well shalt thou not be accepted
god tells cain think look at what you did
if you do what is right if you do well
if you do what i say to do i will accept you as
verily as i accepted abel god did not accept abel
because abel was better looking god accepted abel
because abel did what was right and so the bible
says if thou doest well and the implication
is as able did shalt thou not be accepted
here is an iron principle on which you and i
can lean our total weight god always accepts
right doing always without exception if thou doest
well shalt thou not be accepted is a rhetorical
question but the answer is yes and if thou doest
not well sin lieth at the door now we have a clue
if thou doest well that must be righteousness
because if thou doest not well it is sin
let me try that again i'm not sure you're
following me the bible is a book of opposites
in verse 7 we have that shown
very clearly if thou doest well
shalt thou not be accepted genesis 4 6-7 and if
thou doest not well which is a precise opposite
sin life at the door if sin lies at the door
if sin is the result of not doing well then
the opposite of not doing well is doing well
what is the result of doing well it is god's
acceptance because doing well is righteous
behavior what is righteousness what is sin
let's go earlier as we hold on to the clues we
just received from cain and abel whose two names
make up our title we're looking at the root of sin
the root of righteousness genesis chapter 2 16 17
the bible says and the lord god commanded the man
saying of every tree of the garden thou mayest
freely eat notice the word commanded but of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil thou shalt
not eat of it for in the day thou eatest thereof
thou shalt surely die now the bible says that the
wages of sin is death and so god is telling adam
if you eat you will die because if you eat you sin
i'll restate the only reason why someone
received the punishment of death is because
of sin there is no other reason why god
executes the punishment of death only sin
so when god said in the day that we deserve thou
shalt surely die it is because eating meant sin
then if eating is sin not eating the fruit would
be what righteous behavior in conformity with god
what god said do not eat of this tree now listen
to god when he comes down to investigate what
happened genesis chapter 3 reading from verse 9
and the lord god called unto adam and said unto
him where are thou and he said i heard thy voice
in the garden and i was afraid because i was naked
and i hid myself and he said who told thee that
thou was naked hast thou eaten of the tree whereof
i commanded thee that thou should not eat now
god is asking adam did you do what i told you not
to do in other words did you sin listen to paul
romans 5 verse 19 for as by one man's disobedience
many were made sinners so by so by the
obedience of one shall many be made righteous
what paul is doing he's writing getting
his information from genesis 2 and 3.
he's going back to the roots of sin
the world is in his condition because
of disobedience adam and eve were denied access to
the tree of life because of disobedience now this
is very clearly expressed in genesis 3 when they
were thrown out but to show you how to sometimes
extrapolate and work out truth when it's not
clearly stated listen to revelation 22 14. blessed
are they that do his commandments that they may
have right to the tree of life now paul's right
there give me one word for do his commandments
a small word begins with an o ends with a y
or they blessed are they that do his commandments
that they may have right to the tree of life now
if obedience gives a right to the tree of life why
were adam and eve shut out because they disobeyed
so then sin must be disobedience to god
let's go back to romans 5. this time we
read 18 and then 19. and i want you to do a
comparison between romans 18 and romans 19.
romans 18 says therefore as by the offense of one
the judgment came upon all men to condemnation
even so by the righteousness of one the free
gift came upon all men unto justification of
life now look at the words in chapter 5 verse
18 of romans 5 therefore as by the offense
of one who is that one adam what was his
offense well it is defined in verse 19.
for as by one man's disobedience you see the
offense was disobedience 18 and 19 is saying
the same thing using different words so we have
offense and we have righteousness in verse 18.
we have disobedience and we have obedience in
verse 19 now if you do the comparison offense and
disobedience are the same thing which means that
obedience and righteousness are the same thing
look at those two verses carefully they are saying
the same thing using different words let me give
another example of that this time from the old
testament psalm 33 verse 6 by the word of the lord
where the heavens made and all the hosts
of them by the breath of his mouth now by
the word of the lord where the heavens made the
hosts of them by the breath of his mouth word and
breath there are similar or the same heavens
host the same thing verse nine for he spake
and it was done he commanded it's too
fast speak and commanded the same thing
done and stood fast the same thing now romans 5 18
19 18 says for as the offense by the therefore as
by the offense of one judgment came upon all meant
a condemnation even so by the righteousness of one
the free gift came upon all men to justification
of life and so we have offense and righteousness
the offense is what adam did the righteousness
what christ did verse 19 the disobedience is what
adam did the obedience is what christ did meaning
that obedience and righteousness are the same
offense and disobedience are the same so we
go back now to genesis when adam disobeyed god
he sinned because sin is disobedience of course
the classic example definition is first john
chapter 3 verse 4 whosoever committee
of sin transgresseth also the law
for sin is the transgression of the law but
reduce it to one word sin is disobedience
and so god said to cain if thou doest well
let me pause on do many christians when you
talk about doing what's right they accuse you
of legalism immediately take a casual glance
of the bible from genesis to revelation get
a concordance look at the word righteousness
and see the overwhelming frequency with which
righteousness is expressed in the context of doing
what did jesus say matthew 7 21 not everyone
that safe unto me lord lord shall enter into
the kingdom of heaven but he that what
doeth righteousness is right doing sin
is wrongdoing but there's one standard that
determines what's right or what's wrong
and that's the law of god let me say that again
there is only one standard of right and wrong
and that is the law of god so if righteousness is
right doing then righteousness must be conformity
with god's law if sin is wrongdoing then sin is
anti the standards of god's law and so the law
of god sits smack dab in the middle it determines
what is righteousness it determines what is sin
listen to genesis 2 verse 16 and
the lord god commanded the man
he repeats the word in verse 11
and in verse 17 of chapter 3.
now the only way to sin is to transgress the
law so if adam sinned and he did whatever when
god said you shall not eat that was a command
and that somehow was an expression of god's law
because the only way to sin is to transgress
god's law whether in thought word or deed
so when god said when the bible says the lord
god commanded the man saying of every tree of
the garden down this freely eat but of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil thou
shalt not eat of it for in the day thou eat his
thereof thou shalt surely die that was a command
and when adam partook of the fruit along
with his wife they broke god's command
because sin is a transgression of god's law we
did not have to wait for first john chapter three
four thousand years after eden it's right there in
genesis 3 and genesis 2. any deviation from thus
saith the lord is sin conformity with
thus saith the lord is righteousness
now let's go to first john again first
john you read from verse 7 of first john
now my favorite book is genesis
my second favorite book is john
the gospel of john and his epistles
first second third john and of course
his masterpiece the book of revelation first
john 3 7 little children let no man deceive you
he that what do with righteousness is righteous
even as he is righteous now verse it says he that
committeth sin is of the devil what we have are
two opposite behaviors in verse seven he that
do with righteousness is righteous even as he
is righteous verses says he that committeth sin
it is both a doing on both sides this is not
legalism yes righteousness begins with a condition
you're transformed by god yes yes yes you must
have a righteous mind to do righteous acts yes
but somewhere in the righteous mind how do
you know the person has a righteous mind
that's why jesus says a tree
is known by what his fruits
sin is a fruit righteousness is a fruit
a good tree cannot bring forth evil fruit
and an evil tree cannot bring forth
good fruit and so john 1 john 3 4 7
and 8 verse 7 says my little children let no
man deceive you he that do with righteousness
righteousness is a doing that proceeds from a
righteous mind verse 8 he that committeth sin
now this may sound a little funny but we can also
say in verse 7 he that committeth righteousness
commit is just to do that's all it is you do
righteousness you're right with god you do sin
you're on the wrong side of god so we have he that
committed sin is of the devil now let's use the
principle of opposites he that doeth righteousness
is of whom of god not an accidental act of right
we're talking about lifestyles frequent choices
a christian can make a mistake and commit a sin
that does not make the person a child of the
devil we're talking about a lifestyle of sin
a path of sin that's what john is talking about
not an occasional mistake which god's people make
what is righteousness righteousness is
doing what is right what is righteousness
righteousness is plain and simple obedience to the
word of god and where is the word of god condensed
where is the will of god for us condensed
what is this thing that's the whole duty
of man and by the way the whole duty of
angels fear god and keep his commandments
righteousness is living in conformity with
god's law sin is the violation of god's law
there are some people who say and i've heard
and read that sin is not only what you do
sin is your condition your
nature is sin let's examine that
to see if that has any biblical support
that your nature is sin when god forgives
he carries out a transfer we see that in the first
three chapters of genesis genesis 3. let's read
verse 7 of chapter 3 and the eyes of them both
were opened and they knew that they were naked
and they saw fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons that's what they were that
was their sin and they attempt to fix their own
lives which no human being can do that's god's
work so that represented righteousness by works
uh one's own effort to fix one's spiritual problem
so essentially sin in verse 21 of chapter three
unto adam also and to his wife that the lord god
make courts of skins and clothed them now i said
when god forgives there's an act of transference
use your imagination staying in the root of
this truth what is righteousness what is sin
i want you to picture adam and eve
in verse seven of chapter three
they are wearing their own creation i put the
word creation in quote in a quotation marks
aprons of leaves god is not involved at all
listen to verse 7 of chapter 3 and the eyes of
them both were opened and they knew that they
were naked and they sold fig leaves together
and made themselves five pronouns all referring to
adam and eve god is not involved in self-salvation
god is not involved in salvation by works god is
not involved in i am able to fix my own spiritual
problems god is not involved only adam and eve
were involved listen to verse 21 unto adam also
and to his wife did the lord god make coats
of skins and clothe them in verse seven
the aprons were made entirely by adam and eve in
verse 21 the courts are made entirely by god but
there is cooperation between god and the sinner
because surely adam and eve had to allow god
to remove the aprons of leaves now someone may
say but that's not in the verse fine it's not
there in words it is thereby bold and unmistakable
implication let's go to zechariah chapter three
reading from verse one and he showed me joshua the
high priest standing before the angel of the lord
and satan standing at his right hand to resist
him and the lord said then to say in the lord
rebuke thee o satan even the lord which have
chosen jerusalem rebuke thee is not this a bran
plucked out of the fire now joshua was clothed
in filthy garments and stood before the angel
and he answered and spoken to those that stood
before him saying take away the filthy garments
from him and unto him he said behold i have caused
that iniquity to pass from thee and will clothe
thee with change of raymond now what's going
on this is the depiction of forgiveness right
uh justification by faith there is a removal
of one garment and a putting on of the other
of course the filthy garment
in verse 3 represents sin
the new garments represents
the righteousness of christ
now we go back to genesis 3. the righteousness
of christ is not designed to cover sin
replaces sin so forgiveness is a giving for a fear
me to give for to carry away to bear away behold
the lamb of god which taketh away the sins of the
world john 1 29. so god clearly had to remove the
aprons of leaves in order to clothe them in the
coats of skin if now the carnal nature is a sin
if you go to god and say father forgive me for
having a carnal nature what does god remove he
cannot remove the carnal nature until this mortal
puts on immortality when jesus christ comes back
then it is destroyed until then every saved
person has the carnal nature that's why paul
says in galatians 5 17 for the flesh lusteth
again the spirit and the spirits against the
flesh and these that contrary one to the other
so that he cannot do things you would the saved
person still has a carnal nature but is no longer
ruled by the carnal nature he or she is ruled by
the spirit of christ by the nature of christ he
has a a renewed a spiritual creature according
to john 3 6 that which is born of the flesh is
flesh that which is born of the spirit the spirit
we always have the carnal nature until this
martial puts on immortality so if the carnal
nature is a sin how does god forgive it because
forgiveness requires the removal of something and
replacing it with something else my brothers and
sisters the carnal nature is not a sin for which
god holds you and me responsible or guilty now
i am not praising the carnal nature by any means
the carnal age is a terrible thing it originated
with satan by the way not adam was satan that's
why jesus told the pharisees in john 8 44 ye
of your father the devil the carnal nature
is a terrible thing it's a bad thing but the
reason why it is not charged to us as a sin
is based on this absolutely critical principle
when studying the subject of sin sin is a choice
are you with me sin is a choice the
carnal nature is not a choice we made
sin is a choice righteousness is a choice
and so god says in deuteronomy 3 19
i call heaven and earth to record this day
against you that i have set before your life
and death blessing and cursing therefore choose
let me show you a sin is a choice let's reread
genesis 2 16 17 as we continue cain and abel
righteousness and sin and as i said earlier i'm
trying to pack in 30 40 minutes what would take
days and days and weeks of sermons to really
flesh out and the lord god commanded the man
saying of every tree of the garden thou
mayest freely eat but of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil thou shalt not eat
of it for in the day thou eatest thereof thou
shalt surely die those are god's words thou shalt
surely die sin is a choice now genesis 3 verse 1
now the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the lord god had made
and he said unto the woman yea hath god said
ye shall not eat of every tree of the garden
and the woman said unto the serpent we may
eat of the fruit of the trees of the garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is in the midst
of the garden god hath said he shall not eat of it
neither shall he touch it lest he die and the
serpent said unto the woman verse 4 genesis 3
he shall not surely die now here is a
choice as to which word to accept god said
don't eat if you eat you die the
serpent said if you eat you live
by the way it's amazing that people follow the
devil the devil says that sin brings benefits
god says sin has none the devil says sin brings
benefits your eyes open you become like god
and people go for that here's
god's word thou shalt surely die
here's satan's word he shall not
surely die now eve had to choose
whose word will i accept and she chose the
devil's word now let's go to adam genesis 3
verse 17 and unto adam he said because thou has
hearken unto the voice of thy wife now let's use
our minds again what is god implying when he said
because that has hearkened unto the voice of thy
wife i'll tell you what he's implying because
you listen to someone else instead of to me
because you chose another voice instead of
mine because you followed another voice of
authority instead of mine curse is the
ground for thy sake because you chose
contrary to my word a curse
comes on the entire earth sin
the curse on the earth is the result of
a choice to go contrary to god's command
because thou has hearkened unto
the voice of thy wife adam chose
eve chose sin as early as genesis 3 is a choice
now there's such a thing as an ignorant sin
the times of this ignorance god winked at acts
17 30. if i had not come and spoken unto them
they had not had sin but now they have no
cloak for their sin john 15 verse 21 22
so god understands an ignorant sin
but an ignorant sin is still a sin and
that needs to sink in now god does not
charge us with guilt there's no guilt from
an ignorant sin that's how merciful god is
no guilt is associated with an ignorant
sin because the person doesn't know
you see for you and me to sin and
receive guilt we must have knowledge
there are people who will be in heaven who never
kept the sabbath while it was on this earth they
didn't know they did not know god does not hold
them guilty but before they enter the gates on
the road on the trip to heaven they will keep a
sabbath somewhere in in space god does not charge
us with guilt when we sin ignorantly because
for there to be guilt there must be knowledge
without knowledge we cannot make a choice and i
said sin is a choice adam and eve had knowledge
no guesswork knowledge leave the tree alone
if you eat you die the devil said you eat you
live they had a choice and they can exercise a
choice because they had the benefit of knowledge
what is sin what is sin that has guilt sin that
incurs guilt is a willful deliberate intentional
conscious violation of the known will of god
let me say that again sin that incurs guilt
not all sin incurs guilt a genuinely ignorant sin
which means i didn't know i had no way of knowing
does not incur guilt and god overlooks that
but it still goes on jesus because a sin is
a sin you see the law does not care if the sin is
ignorant or willful it doesn't care the law says
the soul that sinneth it shall die if i sin
ignorantly i have still sinned and the law says
you must die god in his mercy says yes the death
penalty must be executed but there's someone who
will take that penalty from him and it goes on
to christ so let me make it very clear there's
nothing glamorous about an ignorant sin it still
damages you it still causes pain for christ but in
his mercy god does not charge the person who sins
out of genuine ignorance sin that incurs guilt is
the willful intentional deliberate violation
of the revealed will of god this was the case
with adam and eve in the garden of eden they were
not deceived eve was to some degree adam was not
but if eve had stayed by adam's side as instructed
by the angels and christ she would not have found
herself in the position where she could be tempted
by the devil working through the the serpent what
have we said about cain and abel righteousness
and sin righteousness at a practical level a
working definition is right doing not just right
saying it is right doing that is why ii peter
chapter 3 verse 13 nevertheless we according to
his promise look for new heavens and new earth
wherein dwelleth righteousness righteousness
my friends is right doing sin is wrongdoing
the follow-up to righteousness as
right doing is how by what power
the power of the indwelling christ because
a sinner cannot live a righteous life
by himself or herself because a
righteous life is the very life of god
that i need to say again when god said let
us make man in our image his intention was
adam's life would reflect his life adam
can't be god but he had to live like god
he had to be like god the very life of
god had to be the life by which he lived
righteousness is living the life of god and no
sinner can do that by himself it is through the
indwelling power of the righteous christ and
so when i say righteousness is right doing
i am right biblically but a necessary question
is how by the indwelling power of jesus christ
sin is wrongdoing how by the
dwelling power of the devil
the power of sin is satan the power
of righteousness is the life of christ
what is sin sin is the violation
of the law of god one word for that
disobedience in patriarchs and prophets page
49 paragraph two ellen white writes these words
obedience perfect and perpetual was
the condition of eternal happiness on
this condition they were to have access to the
tree of life obedience perfect and perpetual
what does she mean by that perfect and
perpetual obedience all the time in everything
99 obedience is not perfect obedience
three days a week is not perpetual
let me say it again by saying this
the life god intended for adam
was a life that would fit him for heaven angels
unfallen beings seraphim cherubim and god himself
that is righteousness the life required of us that
righteous life that is the life that fits us for
communion association with heavenly beings you've
all heard the expression righteousness by faith
it is nothing more than right doing by faith
deuteronomy 6 25 and it shall be our righteousness
if we observe to do all the
commandments before the lord our god
as he hath commanded us conformity with god's law
is righteousness the question is how do i conform
through the indwelling power of jesus christ cain
and abel is our subject cain representing sin able
representing righteousness so we have said that
sin is the violation of the known will of god
why do i say the known will of god is
because there's such a thing as ignorant sin
an ignorant sin does not incur guilt in gospel
workers page 162 paragraph two ella white writes
light makes manifest and reproves the
errors that were concealed in darkness
meaning ignorance and as light comes the life
and character of men must change correspondingly
to be in harmony with it sins that were once sins
of ignorance because of the blindness of the mind
can no more be indulged in without incurring guilt
what she's saying is when the light of truth comes
an ignorant sin ceases to be an ignorant sin
and if it's committed again then it incurs guilt
that's why i define sin as sin that incurs guilt
that's what causes destruction and condemnation
is the willful violation of the known
will of god adam's sin was not ignorant
sinner eve sin was not ignorant it was willful and
so they came under the condemnation of god's law
lastly events page 217 paragraph 5 ella
white writes none will be condemned for
not heeding light and knowledge that they
never had and they could not obtain genuine
ignorance does not bring condemnation for the
sinner the curse goes on to christ what is sin
it is a choice to the wrong with
full knowledge of what is right
me reword that what is sin that brings
condemnation and guilt a choice to do wrong
when having the knowledge of right
which is precisely what adam and eve did
no one will be lost because of ignorance sin
that's not the problem with the world the problem
with the world is direct and willful violation of
god's law the problem with the world is deliberate
disobedience to the plainly spoken word of god and
the lord commanded the man saying do not eat that
was somehow an expression of god's law because
that's the only way to sin and adam went contrary
to that coldly and blatantly and plunged the world
into sin and so we have to ask ourselves is there
an area of my life where i am willfully disobeying
god willfully while i sing the hymns very loudly
willfully disobey god i am placing myself under
condemnation i am flirting with death not just
death that's the consequence of sin i mean
the second death from which there is no return
am i knowingly intentionally
purposefully violating god's law
if the answer is yes yes then the
same power with which i choose to sin
is the same power by which i can choose to
do what is right by the power of christ that
will with which we exercise the power of choice
my friends life comes down to right and wrong
righteous or sinful obedient or disobedient
christ object lessons page 283 paragraph
three eli white writes these words there
are only two classes in the world today
and only two classes will be recognized in the
judgment those who violate god's law and those
who obey and that goes all the way back to
adam and eve and then cain and abel and all
the way down only two classes listen to this very
fascinating statement here's what the statement
says the only question us in the judgment
will be are they obedient to my commandments
let me say that again the only question asked
in the judgment will be are they obedient to
my commandments that comes from the west
indian messenger july 1 1912 paragraph 5.
now this is essentially what got us when he came
down into the garden listen to god genesis 3 11
who told me that thou was naked hast thou eaten
of the tree of where have i commanded thee thou
should not eat what is god saying did you disobey
me did you obey or did you disobey what did you do
that's what god was asking the only question
because when god came down that was judgment
judgment requires investigation then assigning
the punishment and then carrying it out
you investigate you determine guilt innocence
then you execute whether it's a reward or
punishment christ came what happened spoke to
adam adam said whatever okay adam you be quiet
because judgment is individual not family then
eve by herself what happened yeah fine then god
gave eve her punishment verse 16. then adam his
the snake is in verse 15. but god's essential
question was did you disobey me and otherwise
says the only question asking the judgment
are they obedient to mike did they do what i said
let me tell you something about
the carnal nature as i close
always remember if you find yourself resisting
the concept of obedience always remember
the problem with the carnal nature is god's law
listen to romans 8 7 because the carnal mind is
enmity against god what is enmity hatred hostility
so you ask the question why is the carnal mind
so hostile to god the verse doesn't say it has
hostility it says it is enmity why the verse
explains because it is not subject to the law of
god the law of god is the basis for the enmity
the carnal nature feels towards us towards god
the law of god is the basis for the enmity satan
feels towards god it is the law of god this is
the mind the unconverted person has that directs
his or her life and so the person does not like
the concept of obey but even after conversion
even after conversion when the
child of god is studying the word
the the law-hating mind tries
to corrupt the person study
and so many christians are opposed to obedience
they hate the concept and that is the carnal mind
working its satanic magic in the person's mind
the bible is so simple it's so simple
righteousness is right doing sin
is wrong listen to mary now no one knows you like
your mother not even your father god bless all
fathers no one knows you like your mother and
the third day there was a marriage in cain of
galilee and the mother of jesus was there and
both jesus was called and his disciples to the
marriage and when they wanted wine the mother of
jesus saith unto the servants they have no wine
john chapter 2 verse 1 to 3 verse 4 he saith
unto her woman what have i to do with the mind
hours not yet come verse 5 his mother saith unto
the servants whatsoever he saith unto you do it
if adam and eve had followed that council we would
not be here in this condition let me say it again
mary words are counsel for the whole
world and there's life in that advice
whatever he tells you to do
do it
that's how to live a blessed
life that's a righteous life
the opposite is a sinful life whatever he
tells you to do modify it that's a sinful life
whatever he tells you to do offer some
recommendations that's a sinful life
a sinful life doesn't they call
necessarily include murder and genocide and
fratricide and robbing banks and blowing
up no no no no no it can be just a polite
sophisticated opposition to one area of god's word
that's all just one where there's no surrender
and 99.9 surrender to god qualifies you
for very sophisticated entrance into hell
i urge you from my heart ask god to
give you a mind to do whatever he says
that's what's christ's testimony of his
relationship with his father listen to john 8 29
he that have sent me is with me the father hath
not left me alone why for i do always the things
that please him use the law of opposites
if the father stays with those who do
always the things that please him what
does this add you to those who don't
may god's spirit lead our minds
to fall in love with the concept
of obeying god so that what was said of christ in
prophetic words i delight to do thy will o my god
yea thy lord within my heart that can be said
of us our greatest joy let's obey god remember
when joseph not joseph jacob was deceived
by laban he worked seven years for rachel
when he pulled back that veil i guess he
probably screamed when he saw who it was
sistelia not an attractive woman layman said
seven more years he ended up working 20 years the
bible says this seemed as nothing nothing why he
loved rachel so much the years felt like nothing
when you love god obedience is not sure
it's a lifestyle of love may god bless us
as we follow the path of abel not cain as we
follow the path of righteousness and not sin